hey if you let's support the production
of more move university video tutorials
then please visit the support move
section on Luke universe comm thank you
and enjoy last one is HDL or high
density lipoprotein often called good
cholesterol it is the smallest of
lipoproteins and it is the most dense
lipoprotein it's high density
lipoprotein it is produced in the liver
and intestine and one really important
bit of information about it is that it
has L cat what is L cat L cat is an
enzyme and it is stands for less thin
cholesterol acyl transferase so what it
does is it basically takes cholesterol
and turns it into a cholesterol ester
something I mentioned in the April
proteins a video about a protein a one
we'll talk about that in just a second
but basically it takes cholesterol and
turns them into cholesterol esters and
we've actually seen another enzyme do
this it was a cat which was acyl a sub
Co a cholesterol acyl transferase so the
acyl group came from a nasal co a in
this case the acyl group is not coming
from an ASIC away instead coming from
lecithin or phosphatidylcholine
which looks like this so it's actually a
phospholipid so what happens is that the
acyl group on carbon on the second
carbon of the glycerol backbone is
actually to be taken off and give into
the cholesterol to to basically be that
acyl group that gets attached to make
the cholesterol ester and then on the
second carbon wages have an O H group
left here so we basically take this R or
this acyl group and attach it here to
give our cholesterol ester now we're
left with here is an O age group which
gives us lice so bless it then okay so
that's what L cat does and this is
pretty important because HDL needs to
take the cholesterol well actually
before I even mention that let's talk
about the function of of HDL its main
function is reverse
cholesterol transport which basically
means that it's going to take
cholesterol from the peripheral tissues
back to the liver so why is LK important
well because L cat takes the Colet if
HDL takes up the cholesterol from these
cells it has to make sure that it
doesn't lose them when it before it
takes it back to the liver so it takes
the cholesterol is up from the cells and
converts them into these cholesterol
esters so that they can escape and then
it takes it back to the to the liver as
cholesterol esters another thing that
HDL is important for is that it
exchanges April proteins with other
lipoprotein particles so its main April
proteins which make a protein is a one
that's because it activates L cat if you
mentioned earlier so that's super
important also it has c2 as well as E
and it gives those to kind of microns
and also give them to vldls as we saw
many other videos now reverse
cholesterol transport is pretty
important but it's especially important
in a particular tissue which tissue or
what kind of tissue vascular tissue
because in vascular tissue we're talking
about
HDL taking these these the sequester all
out of those cells because due to excuse
me kind of fumbled over the over my
words a little bit basically to lower
the possibility of forming a thorough
sclerotic plaques sclerotic plaques and
plaques
so if we take the cholesterol out of
these cells we can allow LDL to deliver
cholesterol to those cells basically the
ratio between LDL and HDL is important
we'll see that how that works in just a
second but HDL have has an anti
atherosclerosis
it is kind of anti atherosclerosis
cholesterol cholesterol molecules away
from these cells and it's especially
important in vascular tissue so that
we don't have these these plaques
develop and eventually obstruct blood
flow again more on that another video so
how is HDL made there are three
different ways where HDL can be made one
way is the one that we're kind of going
to look at in the diagram below is all
the components are put together give in
the liver or an intestine we're going to
think about it as far as the liver goes
another ways that HDL it can be formed
from the budding off of able proteins
from chylomicrons which kind of explains
the parenthesis from chylomicrons
portion in the chart on the AVO proteins
in part two of this series so I
encourage you to check that out if you
haven't already another thing is that
freely circulating a PO a ones can just
pick up lick lick lipid components and
form an HDL lipoprotein so that that's
how you make the nascent hdls and they
can they have to mature though the
maturation is not very well understood
basically what happens is that you have
a shell like HDL which can become
globular and it it was involved what is
known as involved is the addition of
phospholipids cholesterol and
cholesterol esters to the nation
particle to give you the mature particle
mechanism by which that actually occurs
is unknown it's not one well it's not
well understood so I don't really know
too much about it but I do know or I did
discover this much so let's look at the
diagram to sort of follow HDL what it
does so let's start up here at the top
where we have HDL it's got a 1 C 2 and E
all attached to it it's got L CAD in
there and we said that it exchanges the
April proteins with other lipoprotein
particles including the chylomicrons and
VLDL so it's going to give c2 and e to
both the chylomicron to allow that to
mature and it also gives it to the VLDL
to allow that to mature when it does
that it ends up having just just the a1
down here on the right
and then where does it go to these
peripheral tissues and it takes
cholesterol cholesterol molecules from
peripheral tissues and it picks them up
and once it does pick them up it's got
these cholesterol it has the L cat
available so as to convert these
cholesterol into cholesterol esters so
that they do not escape the lipoprotein
particle then what they can do the key
thing here is to follow this arrow where
they'll be taken back to the liver and
on the way there
April April and April c2 will come back
on to the HDL particle and this is
because you see little asterisks here is
because after the chylomicrons and vldls
are digested the a po c 2 and a po e can
go back to the HDL and that's good
because we need HDL to be able to be
taken up by the liver and is that a bowi
to bind the apoE receptor so that i can
be taken up and these lysosomes can then
fuse with the particle and then give us
the cholesterol back in the liver here
and of course that cholesterol can give
us steroids or bile salts or whatever
whatever the cells need okay now that's
this is basically so if we're thinking
about reverse cholesterol transport
we're really thinking about about this
part here right reverse cholesterol
transport RCT here taking the
cholesterol into the HDL and then taking
them along this this line here right
back to the liver
that's reverse cholesterol transport now
there is this protein called cholesterol
ester transfer protein abbreviated as
CTP which is shown here what that does
is that mediates
the sort of trade that HDL particles can
have with the LDL particles so basically
HDL can take as cholesterol esters and
give them to the vldls in exchange for
triglycerides triglycerides would be
given to the H
from vldls now I'm actually not sure why
this occurs I know that it happens and
that CET P gives us up and I'm not
really sure why this would actually
occur this kind of gets in the way of
reverse cholesterol transport and this
VLDL of course can give rise to ideal or
LDL and what that would end up meaning
is that we could potentially have more
cholesterol more LDL cholesterol in the
blood so CET P I'm not really exactly
sure what its purpose is I'd lift it up
a little bit but I couldn't really find
much on it other than the idea that
there are thoughts that there can be
drugs that inhibit this so as to treat
hypercholesterolemia because like I said
this kind of gets in the way of reverse
cholesterol transport right because it's
not letting HDL take cholesterol esters
back to the liver like it's supposed to
so so the idea is that if C ETP can be
inhibited more HDL can allow more HDL
can actually get reverse cholesterol
transport to happen so so CTP inhibitors
are are being investigated as potential
treatments for for a
hypercholesterolemia I don't really know
too much about that but if you do know
something that I haven't mentioned here
about CET P and you'd like to mention it
please please feel free to mention in
the comment section and share your
knowledge and understanding about this
thing because I'm actually a little bit
confused about it so yeah share the
knowledge if you got it yeah so that's
basically it for what HDL does now
something that's important is the ratio
of LDL to HDL so LDL hanging out in the
blood can be damaging of course because
of the oxidized LDL can become foam
cells it can eventually lead to the
formation of foam cells whereas HDL kind
of reduces that possibility from
happening right if it's taking the
cholesterol out of these peripheral
tissues and taking them back to the
liver that kind of reduces the
possibility that
um that LDL will end up hanging out in
the blood so something that's used as a
diagnostic tool in medicine is the LDL
to HDL ratio so if you have an LDL race
LDL to HDL ratio that's less than or
equal to three point five that's
considered good and healthy and what
that really means is that there you have
the right amount of cholesterol in your
blood and in your cells because
basically you have a good amount of HDL
per LDL okay but if you have an LDL
that's much higher than HDL you're kind
of overwhelming your ability to to to
work in anti atherosclerosis
so basically an LDL ratio LDL to HDL
ratio that's higher than 3.5 is
considered bad and this basically means
is that there's too much cholesterol in
the blood and in the cells the LDL is
too high relative to the HDL so they can
kind of think about it as LDL kind of
the more LDL you have the more likely it
is that these foam cells will form and
the more HDO that you have the less
likely that's going to happen so you
kind of want more HDL and and less LDL
in order to achieve what would be
considered a healthy ratio of less than
3.5 now I'm not by any means giving
medical advice here if you have any
concerns about this stuff definitely can
consult your physician but these are
just ratios that are are used in the
field okay
I hope that video is helpful thank you
for watching thanks for watching be sure
to LIKE comment subscribe and don't
forget to share the video with anyone
who you think might find it helpful
thanks and happy studying